For 35 years, Scharlette Holdman has worked with defense teams on death penalty cases, including some very high profile cases. But she hasn't given an interview to the press in decades, ever since an incident where she had a few drinks with a reporter and said some things that she was unhappy to see in print.
35年来，沙莱特·霍德曼（Scharlette Holdman）一直与死刑案件的辩护团队合作，其中包括一些非常引人注目的案件。但几十年来，她从未接受过媒体采访，起因是曾有一次她和一名记者喝了几杯酒，说了一些让她事后看到见报很不高兴的话。
It was so embarrassing. And I thought, well, I either have to quit drinking or quit doing interviews. And I wasn't ready to quit drinking yet, so I quit doing interviews. So this interview is a very rare event for me. I haven't done any kind of interviews with the media since '85.
那太尴尬了。我想，要么戒酒，要么不再接受采访。但我还没准备好戒酒，所以我停止了接受采访。所以，这次采访对我来说是一件非常罕见的事情。自85年以来，我没有接受过任何媒体的任何采访。
And you are ending the moratorium, in this one instance, for this story. Why?
而你为了这个故事，打破了这项禁令。为什么？
Well, a fluffy, red-combed leghorn deserves his moment in the sun. I mean just the image-- and I'm not talking about any chicken. I'm talking about-- you can just picture it-- this beautiful leghorn, his tail perked up, and that red comb sitting at kind of a rakish angle on his head, and his head kind of cocked to the side, and he looks at you with his little eyes. That's what this story is about.
嗯，一只蓬松、红冠的来航鸡值得拥有属于它的高光时刻。我的意思是，仅仅是那个形象——我说的不是普通的鸡。我说的是——你可以想象一下——这只美丽的来航鸡，尾巴翘起，那红色的鸡冠以一种俏皮的角度斜在头上，脑袋歪向一边，用它那小小的眼睛看着你。这就是这个故事的内容。
That is not just what this story is about. That is what a lot of today's radio show is about. Ever since the early days of our radio show, once a year, during the highest poultry-consumption time of our country, which is of course-- if you think about this for even a moment, you can guess the answer to this-- it's the weeks that begin with Thanksgiving and go through Christmas and New Year's.
这不仅仅是这个故事的内容。这也是今天电台节目的重要内容。自从我们电台节目的早期开始，每年在我国禽肉消费量最高的时期——如果你仔细想一想，你就能猜出答案——那就是从感恩节开始，一直持续到圣诞节和新年的那几周。
During that time, it's a tradition here. We devote an entire hour of our program to stories of chickens, turkeys, ducks, foul of all kind. And in homage to Chicago's poetry slams, which have spread across the country but were created at the Green Mill Bar on the North Side by poet Marc Smith, we named these programs "Poultry Slams."
在那段时间里，这是这里的一个传统。我们将节目的整整一小时专门用于讲述鸡、火鸡、鸭子和各种家禽的故事。为了向芝加哥的诗歌朗诵赛（poetry slams）致敬——这种比赛风靡全国，但最初是由诗人马克·史密斯（Marc Smith）在北区的绿磨坊酒吧（Green Mill Bar）创办的——我们将这些节目命名为“家禽朗诵赛”（Poultry Slams）。
But I just want to be clear before we even begin. We're using the word "slam" with no malice toward any bird of any kind at all. No birds were hurt, no birds were slaughtered, no birds were slammed in the making of today's program. And we have incredible stories today, incredible enough that at least one woman has ended a quarter-century moratorium on talking to the press to be here with me. And you should too. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
但在我们开始之前，我想明确一点。我们使用“猛击”（slam）这个词，对任何鸟类绝无恶意。在今天节目的制作过程中，没有鸟类受到伤害，没有鸟类被屠宰，也没有鸟类被“猛击”。今天我们有不可思议的故事，不可思议到至少有一位女性结束了长达四分之一个世纪的媒体禁令来到这里。你也应该留下来。这是来自WBEZ芝加哥的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, "Witness for the Barbecue-tion." So Scharlette Holdman didn't just get the idea of calling a chicken as a witness in a murder case out of the blue. She was working on this case-- and we're going to call this guy Harry-- and there was no question that the guy had killed somebody. This wasn't about whether he'd done it. It was just about what sentence he would get. He had sat on death row at San Quentin for 10 years. But Scharlette says he was schizophrenic with an IQ of 58 and just out of touch with reality.
第一幕，“烧烤证人”。所以沙莱特·霍德曼并不是突发奇想要在谋杀案中传唤一只鸡作为证人。她当时正在处理这个案子——我们姑且叫这个家伙哈里（Harry）——毫无疑问，这家伙杀了一个人。这不是关于他是否犯了罪。而是关于他会被判什么刑。他在圣昆汀（San Quentin）死囚牢房里坐了10年。但沙莱特说他患有精神分裂症，智商只有58，而且与现实脱节。
And one of the things he did-- he wrote messages and symbols on little pieces of toilet paper and rolled them up in a ball. And he'd done this for years on death row-- rolled the little secret messages up in a ball and then rolled them in feces, his own feces, and then into little, tiny, bead-sized balls and put those into the braids in his hair.
他做的一件事就是把信息和符号写在小纸条上，揉成球。他在死囚牢房里这样做了多年——把这些秘密信息揉成球，然后裹上粪便，他自己的粪便，揉成米粒大小的珠子，放进他头发的辫子里。
Oh my.
天哪。
So that they dangled around his forehead.
所以它们就在他额头周围晃荡。
And the things he was putting in his hair-- from his point of view, were they communicating some information, the little messages?
他塞进头发里的东西——从他的角度来看，是在传达什么信息吗？
Exactly. But he couldn't tell me what the messages were because they were secret. When I would talk to him about his mother, he would tell me she lived in a Coca-Cola can.
没错。但他不能告诉我这些信息是什么，因为它们是秘密。当我和他谈起他的母亲时，他会告诉我她住在一个可口可乐罐里。
It's against the law to execute somebody who is so crazy he doesn't understand why he's being executed. And Scharlette said that was true for this guy.
法律规定，处决一个疯到不明白自己为何被处决的人是违法的。沙莱特说，这对这个家伙来说是真的。
When I would say, do you know what's going to happen on the 12th of June, he was kind of befuddled and, with pressure, he would finally say, well yeah, he thought he was going to be reupholstered.
当我问他，你知道6月12日会发生什么吗？他有点困惑，在压力之下，他终于说，嗯，是的，他认为他会被重新装潢。
The state of California did not agree with Scharlette about this guy. They wanted to execute him in 30 days. Scharlette's team was making a last-ditch appeal to stay this execution. Meanwhile, the state was gathering its evidence.
加利福尼亚州不同意沙莱特对这个人的看法。他们想在30天内处决他。沙莱特的团队正在做最后的上诉以暂缓执行死刑。与此同时，州政府正在收集证据。
San Quentin sent in a prison psychiatrist to determine-- was he competent to be executed? Did he know he was going to be executed? And did he know why he was going to be executed? So the psychiatrist goes and interviews Harry. And then this psychiatrist testified in court that not only was Harry aware that he was going to be executed, she was so certain of this because she had played Tic-tac-toe with him and Harry had beat her.
圣昆汀派了一名监狱精神科医生来确定——他是否有资格被处决？他知道自己要被处决吗？他知道为什么会被处决吗？于是精神科医生去采访了哈里。然后，这位医生在法庭上作证说，哈里不仅意识到自己要被处决，而且她如此确信这一点，因为她曾和哈里玩过井字棋（Tic-tac-toe），而哈里赢了她。
Well, it was so absurd and so outside of any normal experience in a courtroom. And this is after 30 years of being in death penalty cases in the South, around the world, and-- I really couldn't believe she had said it. But at the same time, the only image that came to me-- I'm from the South, obviously. And growing up, we always went to the Mid-South Fair. And they had a chicken that played Tic-tac-toe that absolutely mesmerized me. And it was pretty clear to me-- OK, we've got to find a chicken who can play Tic-tac-toe.
嗯，这太荒谬了，完全超出了法庭上的正常体验。这还是在南方以及世界各地处理了30年死刑案件之后——我真的不敢相信她会这么说。但与此同时，我脑海中浮现出的唯一画面——显然，我来自南方。从小到大，我们总是去中南博览会（Mid-South Fair）。他们有一只会玩井字棋的鸡，那真的让我着迷。对我来说很清楚——好吧，我们得找一只会玩井字棋的鸡。
Scharlette thought-- and this is not a joke. It's not an exaggeration. She thought that a chicken like that could save this man's life. Jurors, after all, tend to believe the state and its witnesses. And a chicken like that could totally undermine the psychiatrist's testimony by proving that playing Tic-tac-toe doesn't mean that you understand things like why you're being executed.
沙莱特认为——这不是开玩笑。这不是夸张。她认为这样的鸡能救这个人的命。毕竟，陪审员往往相信州政府及其证人。而那样的鸡完全可以证明玩井字棋并不意味着你能理解为什么被处决，从而彻底动摇这位精神科医生的证词。
I just knew a chicken would work. It's a sad state. But I think a chicken has more credibility than the defense team did. And I think it would have brought the jury over to seeing us as people rather than as these obstructionists who were interfering with an execution.
我只是知道鸡会奏效。这是一种悲哀的状态。但我认为鸡比辩护团队更有信誉。而且我认为这会让陪审团把我们看作是人，而不是阻碍执行死刑的阻挠者。
And who can doubt a chicken? You can't. Chickens aren't going to lie. Chickens have integrity.
谁会怀疑一只鸡呢？你不能。鸡不会撒谎。鸡有诚信。
I had this image of the psychiatrist being on the stand. And I would quietly enter through the wood doors as they opened with this beautiful leghorn under my arm, right, and a comb at a rakish angle. And as I walked into the courtroom, not saying a word, and quietly took a seat on the front row, the psychiatrist-- who we knew, because we'd investigated her background-- was from New York City, would see a person with a chicken and think, why is that-- oh my god, no. And that psychiatrist would slowly realize that she was going to have to play Tic-tac-toe with a chicken.
我脑子里有这样一个画面：精神科医生在证人席上。我悄悄地从木门走进去，腋下夹着这只美丽的来航鸡，对吧，鸡冠呈一个俏皮的角度。当我走进法庭，一言不发，安静地在第一排坐下时，那位精神科医生——我们调查过她的背景，知道她来自纽约市——会看到一个带着鸡的人，心想，为什么那是——哦，天哪，不。那位精神科医生会慢慢意识到，她必须和一只鸡玩井字棋。
So you're trying to psych out-- you were trying to get inside the psychiatrist's head and--
所以你是想在心理上——你是想进入那个精神科医生的脑子里，然后——
Exactly. Exactly.
没错。没错。
--And make the psychiatrist unravel even before you pull your stunt.
——并且在她实施计划之前就让她崩溃。
The jury's eyes, as awareness overcame her. So it wouldn't work with a frazzled chicken. I didn't want a splotchy, beat-up, tired, exhausted chicken. I wanted a chicken that could capture the audience's attention, in this case the audience was the jury.
当意识击中她时，陪审团的眼睛。所以用一只疲惫的鸡是行不通的。我不想要一只身上有斑点、受了伤、疲惫不堪的鸡。我想要一只能够吸引观众注意力的鸡，在这个案例中，观众就是陪审团。
Right. You'd need a chicken like in a cartoon.
对。你需要一只像卡通片里那样的鸡。
Look, I had to have a chicken that could take on a psychiatrist. It had to be a stand-up chicken.
听着，我必须有一只会对抗精神科医生的鸡。它必须是一只会挺身而出的鸡。
Noted.
知道了。
So we began to hunt for this stand-up chicken.
于是我们开始寻找这只会“挺身而出”的鸡。
Well, this task fell to the legal interns. The man was scheduled to die, at that point, in less than two weeks. And they needed a chicken. And they searched the places that you find Tic-tac-toe-playing chickens, namely county fairs, carnivals. And really, within hours, they found a Tic-tac-toe-playing goose in Montana. But, of course, Scharlette says, that was totally unacceptable.
好吧，这个任务落到了法律实习生身上。当时那个男人被安排在不到两周后就要死。他们需要一只鸡。他们搜寻了能找到玩井字棋鸡的地方，也就是县集市、嘉年华。真的，几个小时之内，他们在蒙大拿州找到了一只会玩井字棋的鹅。但是，当然，沙莱特说，那完全不可接受。
Geese are nasty. They bite you. I didn't want a goose running around the courtroom chasing someone.
鹅很讨厌。它们会咬人。我可不想让一只鹅在法庭上跑来跑去追人。
Next was a guy at a roadside stand in Wyoming who did have a chicken, and it did play Tic-tac-toe, but he said that flying or driving it to California for the trial would probably upset it so much that he could not guarantee that it would win the game of Tic-tac-toe, so he was out. Finally, they found a fellow in Arkansas who trains chickens to play Tic-tac-toe. And he had a whole list of chickens that he had trained around the country. And he sent the legal team to one of those birds in San Francisco. That turned out to be a dead end. San Francisco had actually passed an ordinance banning the playing of Tic-tac-toe by chickens as animal cruelty.
接下来是怀俄明州路边摊的一个人，他确实有一只会玩井字棋的鸡，但他表示，为了审判把它飞运或开车运到加州可能会让它太不安，以至于他不能保证它能赢下比赛，所以他出局了。最后，他们在阿肯色州找到了一个训练鸡玩井字棋的家伙。他有一份在全国各地训练过的鸡的名单。他让法律团队去旧金山找其中一只鸟。结果是个死胡同。旧金山实际上已经通过了一项法令，禁止鸡玩井字棋，认为这是虐待动物。
Fortunately, another chicken on the list was not far from there-- at the boardwalk at Santa Cruz. They had their chicken.
幸运的是，名单上的另一只鸡离那儿不远——在圣克鲁斯的木板路上。他们有他们的鸡。
So the next step was to convince the court to let us bring the chicken to court as a witness, as demonstrative evidence, to introduce the chicken and let the chicken play Tic-tac-toe. Now of course, I wanted the chicken to play Tic-tac-toe with the psychiatrist. But I realized--
所以下一步就是说服法庭允许我们把这只鸡带进法庭作为证人，作为演示证据，介绍这只鸡并让它玩井字棋。当然，我希望鸡能和那位精神科医生玩井字棋。但我意识到——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--yeah-- that most likely, no one was going to let us get away with that. But I did think that any of us-- we have a healthy group of interns. They know how to play Tic-tac-toe so that we could demonstrate to the jury that playing Tic-tac-toe did not mean that you were aware of the consequences of your actions.
——是的——最有可能的是，没人会让我们得逞。但我确实认为我们中的任何一个人——我们有一群健康的实习生。他们知道怎么玩井字棋，这样我们就可以向陪审团演示，玩井字棋并不意味着你意识到自己行为的后果。
Why wouldn't you be allowed to make the psychiatrist play Tic-tac-toe with the chicken? I understand why the psychiatrist would not want to do it. But from a legal point of view, what line does that cross?
为什么不允许你让精神科医生和鸡玩井字棋？我明白为什么精神科医生不想这样做。但从法律角度来看，这越过了什么界限？
Well, evidently-- I agree with you-- but the court felt-- it never addressed the issue of having to play the psychiatrist. But the court felt that bringing the chicken into the courtroom to play Tic-tac-toe would degrade the dignity of the court. I thought that the dignity of the court was degraded by executing a mentally retarded, mentally ill person.
嗯，显然——我同意你的看法——但法庭认为——它从未处理过不得不让精神科医生玩棋的问题。但法庭觉得把鸡带进法庭玩井字棋会降低法庭的尊严。我认为处决一个智力迟钝、有精神疾病的人才是降低了法庭的尊严。
So the court denied our motion and said we could not bring the chicken into the courtroom for demonstrative evidence. It ruled against us.
所以法庭驳回了我们的动议，说我们不能把鸡带进法庭作为演示证据。它做出了对我们不利的裁决。
They weren't even allowed to show the jury a video of the chicken playing Tic-tac-toe. And without a chicken on the stand, without a video of a chicken, the jury found the psychiatrist credible and ruled to execute Scharlette's client. His life was saved later, on appeal. And in the years since then, in 2002, the Supreme Court ruled that a person at his level of mental retardation cannot be executed.
他们甚至不允许向陪审团播放鸡玩井字棋的视频。在没有鸡出庭、没有视频的情况下，陪审团认为精神科医生的证词可信，并裁定处决沙莱特的客户。他的生命后来在上诉中获救。从那以后的几年里，在2002年，最高法院裁定，智力迟钝到他那种程度的人不能被处决。
For Scharlette, though, this story stays with her, this story of the chicken. Because in decades of doing these capital trials, bringing hundreds of witnesses, it is the greatest courtroom move she ever invented, bringing in the chicken. And she never got to try it. She invented this thing. She never got to try it. It was snatched away from her. Something like that sticks in your craw.
不过，对于沙莱特来说，这个故事一直伴随着她，关于那只鸡的故事。因为在几十年的死刑审判中，带过数百名证人，把那只鸡带进法庭是她发明过的最伟大的法庭动作。但她从来没有机会尝试。她发明了它。她从来没有机会尝试。它被从她手中夺走了。像这样的事情会一直梗在心里。
Well, yeah, because I didn't get to do it. But it's also because of the nature and quality of a chicken. When you do this kind of work, when you're down in the worst part-- when you're trying to work for the folks that, literally, the community wants to kill, it can be pretty discouraging. But this nice, fluffy leghorn brightens up your day and you forge on. And all of this, all of this is not to make light of death as punishment, of people with mental retardation, of people who are mentally ill, or of chickens.
嗯，是的，因为我没能做到。但这也有关鸡的天性和品质。当你从事这种工作时，当你身处最糟糕的境地——当你试图为那些社区字面上想要杀死的人工作时，这可能会相当令人沮丧。但这只漂亮的、毛茸茸的来航鸡照亮了你的一天，然后你继续前进。而所有这一切，所有这一切并不是要轻描淡写死刑、智障人士、精神病患者或鸡。
Thank you for saying that.
谢谢你说出这一点。
No, it's really not. I actually am a member of PETA.
不，真的不是。我实际上是善待动物组织（PETA）的成员。
Scharlette Holdman in New Orleans.
在纽奥良的沙莱特·霍德曼。
Act Two, "Murder Most Foul." OK, here's a crazy fact. The number of wild turkeys in America has grown from-- get this-- 30,000 turkeys at the beginning of the 20th century, to 1.3 million turkeys in the 1970s, to about 7 million turkeys today. Seven million wild turkeys roaming all over the country in every state but Alaska, turkeys that, if you believe videos you see on YouTube, could possibly do this to you.
第二幕，“最恶毒的谋杀”。好吧，这里有一个疯狂的事实。美国野生火鸡的数量已经从——听好了——20世纪初的3万只，增长到20世纪70年代的130万只，再到今天的约700万只。700万只野生火鸡在除了阿拉斯加以外的全国各地漫游，如果你相信你在YouTube上看到的视频，它们可能会对你做这种事。
It's pecking the car. It's pissed. It is attacking the car. It wants in here really bad. It's making weird noises. Oh, [BLEEP] get out of here! Oh my gosh.
它在啄车子。它很生气。它在攻击这辆车。它非常想进来。它发出了奇怪的声音。哦，[哔——]快离开这里！天哪。
There are lots of videos like this on the web, of wild turkeys attacking people in residential neighborhoods. And they've been making the local news more lately too. You may have seen this footage that's gone around of this reporter in Sacramento who went to verify reports of a rogue turkey and then got attacked herself.
网上有很多这样的视频，关于野生火鸡在居民区攻击人类。最近它们也越来越多地出现在当地新闻中。你可能看过这段流传的视频，关于萨克拉门托的一名记者，她去核实有关一只流氓火鸡的报道，结果自己也遭到了攻击。
No. Go away. Oh, Jesus Christ. No!
不。走开。噢，天哪。不！
But none of these turkeys come even close to one bird, one bird who unleashed a reign of terror on Martha's Vineyard in 2008. Sam Bungey was a reporter on the island when it all went down.
但这些火鸡都没有哪一只比得上2008年在玛莎葡萄园岛（Martha's Vineyard）引发恐怖统治的那一只。萨姆·邦吉（Sam Bungey）是当时岛上的一名记者。
It was Father's Day around noon, and two things were true on Old Ridge Road in the tiny town of Chilmark-- first, it was Tom the Turkey's last day on Earth. Second, he was not going quietly.
那天是父亲节，中午左右，在奇尔马克（Chilmark）小镇的旧里奇路（Old Ridge Road）上有两件事是真的——第一，那是火鸡汤姆（Tom the Turkey）在世的最后一天。第二，他不会悄悄地离开。
Alissa Keenan runs a business that specializes in rental baby equipment-- cribs, and high chairs, and things like that for families on vacation on Martha's Vineyard. And on that Father's Day, she and one of her drivers pulled up at a summer house on the road to make a delivery. They noticed a turkey in the yard but thought nothing of it. Wild turkeys run all over the island. The driver got out and a second later, Alissa heard shouts.
阿丽莎·基南（Alissa Keenan）经营着一家专门为玛莎葡萄园度假家庭提供婴儿用品租赁服务的生意——婴儿床、高脚椅等等。那个父亲节，她和她的一名司机开车到路边的一间避暑别墅去送货。他们注意到院子里有一只火鸡，但没多想。野生火鸡在岛上到处跑。司机下了车，一秒钟后，阿丽莎听到了呼喊声。
And then I heard rocks flying and hitting the side of the van. And then he came screaming in saying, that crazy turkey's attacking. So I got out and I flapped my arms and said, shoo, like you do to the seagulls at the dump and they fly away. And the turkey came at me.
然后我听到石头飞过来打在货车侧面。接着他尖叫着跑进来，说那只疯火鸡在攻击。所以我下车，挥舞着手臂说“嘘”，就像你在垃圾场赶走海鸥一样，它们就会飞走。结果火鸡向我冲了过来。
It was big, nearly up to her waist. Alissa told my producer, Bryan Ried, and me that she's seen hundreds of wild turkeys and they always run away when you go near them. This one kept rushing her.
它很大，快到她腰部了。阿丽莎告诉我制片人布莱恩·里德（Bryan Ried）和我，她见过数百只野生火鸡，它们靠近时总是会跑掉。而这只却一直冲向她。
And it was pecking with its face, pecking at me. And then we got back in the van, and it was circling the van.
它用脸啄我，啄我。然后我们退回货车里，它开始围着货车转圈。
So you were besieged in the van, basically.
所以你基本上被困在货车里了。
Yes. We were besieged in the van by a turkey.
是的。我们被一只火鸡包围在货车里。
Sheriff's Department Communications. This line is recording.
警长部门通讯处。这条线路正在录音。
Hi. I'm just calling to let you know there is a turkey here that is attacking us. I'm with my driver and he chased us around the van. I've never seen a turkey come after anybody like that. And the people that are coming here have little kids. I don't know if it has rabies or something. But it's definitely not behaving like any of the turkeys I've ever seen.
嗨。我打电话只是想让你知道，这里有一只火鸡在攻击我们。我和我的司机在一起，它围着货车追我们。我从没见过火鸡那样攻击任何人。而且来这里的还有小孩。我不知道它是不是得了狂犬病之类的。但它的行为绝对不像我见过的任何火鸡。
Alissa made the emergency call, she says, not for herself but for the children that would be using this rental gear. At the time, she didn't know that birds can't get rabies. She and the driver dropped the baby equipment out the van window and drove away.
阿丽莎说她拨打了紧急求助电话，不是为了她自己，而是为了即将使用这些租赁设备的儿童。当时，她不知道鸟类不会患狂犬病。她和司机把婴儿用品从车窗扔出去，然后开车离开了。
A half hour later, officers Matt Gebo and Jeff Day rolled up in separate patrol cars. It was a strange scene-- a bunch of beach chairs and strollers and umbrellas lying in a pile. When Gebo stepped out of his cruiser, the turkey charged him. Both officers filed multi-page reports about what happened next.
半小时后，警官马特·格博（Matt Gebo）和杰夫·戴（Jeff Day）分乘两辆巡逻车赶到。现场很奇怪——一堆沙滩椅、婴儿车和遮阳伞乱堆在一起。当格博从巡逻车走出来时，火鸡向他冲去。两位警官就接下来的事情提交了多页的报告。
"Due to the wild turkey's aggression," Gebo wrote, "I jumped up onto the cruiser's push bumper for protection."
“由于野生火鸡的攻击性，”格博写道，“我跳上了巡逻车的推进保险杠以寻求保护。”
From the bumper, Gebo watched as the turkey pursued his partner. It was fast. It got within a few feet and jumped the policemen. casting about for cover, Officer Day, who is about 6 feet tall and in good shape, ran for the baby equipment.
格博在保险杠上看着火鸡追逐他的搭档。它很快。它冲到几英尺内并跳向警察。为了找掩护，身材高大且体格健壮的戴警官跑向婴儿用品堆。
"The turkey chased me around a pile of chairs three times trying to peck me with its beak," Day wrote in his report. "I then kicked it with my boot. It backed up and then charged me again." Day unclipped the holster of his service weapon, a .40 caliber semi-automatic Glock pistol, and leveled his gun at the oncoming turkey. He backed up one more time around the baby equipment and then squeezed off two bullets. The turkey was wounded, but still it kept running.
“火鸡围着一堆椅子追了我三次，试图用喙啄我，”戴在报告中写道。“然后我用靴子踢了它。它后退了，然后再次冲向我。”戴解开了他随身佩戴的.40口径半自动格洛克手枪的枪套，并将枪指向冲过来的火鸡。他绕着婴儿用品后退了一次，然后扣动扳机射出两发子弹。火鸡受伤了，但仍在跑。
"I pursued the bird on foot," Day wrote. And then he fired twice more.
“我在步行的过程中追逐这只鸟，”戴写道。然后他又开了两枪。
We were outside. I was working in the yard and Jonathan was in the garage, and we heard gunshots.
我们在外面。我在院子里干活，乔纳森（Jonathan）在车库里，我们听到了枪声。
This is Linda, who lives next door with her husband, Jonathan. They didn't want us to use their last name, which makes sense given everything that happened next. Linda and Jonathan knew this turkey, cared a lot for this turkey, actually. It wasn't exactly their pet. But he used to hang around in their yard a lot. And they had named him Tom.
这是琳达（Linda），她和丈夫乔纳森住在隔壁。他们不想让我们使用他们的姓氏，考虑到接下来发生的一切，这很合理。琳达和乔纳森认识这只火鸡，实际上非常关心它。它不完全是他们的宠物。但它经常在他们的院子里徘徊。他们给它取名叫汤姆。
Instinctively, we just started running over, which was a stupid thing to do. When you hear gunshots, you don't run toward them. But we just panicked. And we saw them pulling this very bloody turkey out of our woods.
本能地，我们开始跑过去，这真是愚蠢的做法。当你听到枪声时，你不应该朝它们跑过去。但我们只是惊慌失措。我们看到他们正从我们的树林里拖出一只浑身是血的火鸡。
I don't want to go into the details of my interaction with the police officers. The long and the short of it is, I tried to get between my wife and the shooters.
我不想深究我和那些警官之间的互动细节。简而言之，我试图挡在我的妻子和枪手之间。
Jonathan wouldn't tell me much about what happened next. But in a sworn affidavit, he later said, quote, "I was running as fast as I could through the woods, ducking bushes in a panic and flushed with adrenaline, as two of the gunshots were so close that I could see the muzzle flash." The police say there were a total of four shots fired into the turkey, but Jonathan says it was five. He then saw Officer Day holding the turkey by its neck and laughing, saying, it's done.
乔纳森不愿告诉我更多关于接下来发生的事情。但在后来的宣誓陈述中，他说，引述如下：“我正以最快的速度穿过树林，在惊慌中躲避灌木丛，肾上腺素飙升，因为其中两声枪响离我太近了，我甚至能看到枪口的火光。”警方称一共开了四枪射中火鸡，但乔纳森说是五枪。然后他看到戴警官抓住火鸡的脖子在笑，说，解决了。
According to the police, Jonathan was swearing blue murder. "What the [BLEEP] are you [BLEEP] doing?" He shouted.
据警方称，乔纳森当时在恶毒地咒骂。“你们这群[哔——]在干什么？”他喊道。
"This is the Chilmark Police and we're taking care of a problem turkey," said Officer Day.
“这是奇尔马克警察，我们在处理一只问题火鸡，”戴警官说。
Jonathan yelled back, "What are you, an idiot? Stop shooting my turkeys, you [BLEEP] idiots." And then he punched Officer Gebo in the face. According to Linda, it was the police who were being rough with her husband, so she ran to the house and called 9-1-1.
乔纳森回吼道：“你们是什么，白痴吗？别再射杀我的火鸡了，你们这些[哔——]白痴。”然后他一拳打在了格博警官的脸上。据琳达说，是对警察对她丈夫粗暴对待，所以她跑到屋子里拨打了9-1-1。
9-1-1. This is the Sheriff's Department. This line is recorded, what is your emergency?
9-1-1。这里是警长部门。这条线路正在录音，有什么紧急情况？
Yes, I need the state police right away.
是的，我需要州警立刻过来。
Why do you need the state police?
你为什么需要州警？
Because the local police are up here shooting our turkeys and they've got my husband tied up.
因为当地警察正在这里射杀我们的火鸡，他们还把我丈夫捆起来了。
The police have your husband tied up?
警察把你丈夫捆起来了？
Yes, they have him handcuffed because he was trying to get them to stop shooting our turkeys. They killed the turkeys. They're over here killing turkeys-- the local police. I need the state police right away.
是的，他们给他戴上手铐，因为他试图让他们停止射杀我们的火鸡。他们杀了火鸡。他们在这里杀火鸡——当地警察。我需要州警立刻过来。
The state troopers came, but it was too late. The Chilmark Police cuffed Jonathan, read him his rights, and took him to jail. He was charged with resisting arrest and two counts of assault and battery of a police officer.
州警来了，但已经太迟了。奇尔马克警方给乔纳森戴上手铐，宣读了他的权利，并将他带到监狱。他被控拒捕以及两项袭击警员罪。
Tom the Turkey, riddled with bullets, was bundled into a plastic bag as evidence and stowed in the police department freezer.
浑身弹孔的火鸡汤姆被包进塑料袋作为证据，存放在警察局的冷库里。
Just to back up here, before he grew up to attack delivery people and police, Tom was small and cute and fuzzy and an orphan. That's the Tom that Jonathan and Linda first met back in the spring of 2006. Their house is surrounded by lots of fields and woods with a pond. And one day they were watching a brood of wild turkeys that had wandered into their yard when they saw a red-tailed hawk swoop down and try and pick off Tom and his sister.
简单回溯一下，在它长大到攻击送货员和警察之前，汤姆是个小巧、可爱、毛茸茸的孤儿。那是乔纳森和琳达在2006年春天第一次见到汤姆的样子。他们的房子周围环绕着许多田野、树林和池塘。有一天，他们正在看一群野生火鸡走进他们的院子，这时他们看到一只红尾鵟俯冲下来，试图叼走汤姆和它的姐妹。
Jonathan and Linda are animal lovers. They've raised dogs and slugs and lizards. And Jonathan once spent two years on a campaign to domesticate a feral cat. So when they saw the injured baby turkeys, Jonathan says it was hard not to help.
乔纳森和琳达是动物爱好者。他们养过狗、蛞蝓和蜥蜴。乔纳森曾经花了两年时间驯化一只流浪猫。所以当他们看到受伤的小火鸡时，乔纳森说很难不帮忙。
They had cuts on their faces. And we fixed them up and put antibiotic on his little face. And they still were very attached to us, I guess, for this.
它们的脸上都有伤口。我们帮它们包扎好，还在它的小脸上涂了抗生素。我想它们依然因此和我们非常亲近。
So as Tom grew up, he liked to come and hang out. He'd wander off for a couple of days. But he would always come back. He and Jonathan got on really well.
所以随着汤姆长大，它喜欢过来闲逛。它会走开几天。但它总会回来。它和乔纳森相处得非常好。
He'd just sit there and do his thing where he'd gobble around. And if I dropped any birdseed going out to the birdfeeder, he'd scour that. He'd go in the garage, clean that out. And he used to love shiny things. And whenever I'd be working on anything, you'd find him dragging a wrench down the driveway. It's like, where are you going with this?
它就坐在那儿做它的事，咕咕叫。如果我去鸟食喂食器的时候洒了些鸟食，它就会打扫干净。它会走进车库，把那里打扫干净。它以前很喜欢闪亮的东西。每当我在做任何事情的时候，你都会发现它在车道上拖着一把扳手。就像是，你拿着这个要去哪儿？
When news of Tom's murder hit the local papers, I was living on the island. And I can tell you, everyone went crazy over this story, couldn't get enough of it. How in the world did this happen, that gunshots were fired in Chilmark of all places-- a sleepy town where alcohol sales are outlawed and people leave their keys in the ignition, a place where the cops have enough free time that they once responded, with success, to a call about a kid with a blueberry stuck up his nose?
当汤姆被谋杀的新闻传到当地报纸时，我正住在岛上。我可以告诉你，每个人都对这个故事疯狂了，怎么听都不够。这到底是怎么发生的，枪声竟然在奇尔马克这个地方响起——一个禁售酒精、人们不拔车钥匙就能离车的安宁小镇，一个警察闲到曾经成功处理过一起孩子鼻子里塞了蓝莓的报警电话的地方？
The case was discussed in coffee shops and in bars, where people joked about that season's special drink-- four shots of Wild Turkey, or five, depending on whose account you believed. Letters and comments streamed into the local newspapers, some asking serious questions about what the cops did. But in most you could hear the snickering. Just the idea of a turkey attacking seemed ridiculous. A reader warned parents against letting their kids dress as turkeys for Halloween, lest they incur the wrath of the Chilmark P.D.
这件事在咖啡店和酒吧里被热烈讨论，人们开玩笑说那个季节的特饮——四份野火鸡（Wild Turkey），或者五份，取决于你相信谁的说法。信件和评论像洪水一样涌向当地报纸，一些人在认真询问警察的行为。但在大多数评论中，你能听到窃窃私语。仅仅是火鸡会攻击人这个想法就显得很荒谬。一位读者警告父母不要让孩子在万圣节打扮成火鸡，以免招致奇尔马克警方的愤怒。
One paper ran an editorial cartoon of a dopey-looking turkey in a cop's uniform carrying a rifle. This might be one reason why the police officers, even three years later, wouldn't talk to us for this story.
一家报纸刊登了一幅编辑漫画，画着一只看起来呆头呆脑的火鸡穿着警服，扛着步枪。这可能是为什么即便是三年后，这些警官也不愿就这个故事接受我们采访的一个原因。
A guy named Chip posted this comment in the Martha's Vineyard Times, "Did anyone think of simply getting back into their vehicles until the turkey no longer felt threatened? I'm sure it would have gone back to whatever turkeys do if left alone for five or ten minutes. Or did this turkey have a long list of priors that made him particularly scary?"
一个叫奇普（Chip）的家伙在《玛莎葡萄园时报》上发表了这条评论：“有人想过只需回到车里，直到火鸡不再感到受威胁吗？我相信如果让它们待五到十分钟，它就会回到火鸡该做的事情上。还是说这只火鸡有很长的前科，让它变得特别可怕？”
Well, as it turns out Chip, yeah, he did-- a surprisingly long list of priors.
嗯，结果是，奇普，是的，它确实有——前科清单长得惊人。
I was totally relieved, totally relieved that the turkey was dead-- definitely singing choruses of "Ding Dong the Witch is Dead," yeah.
我完全释怀了，完全释怀了，那只火鸡死了——绝对是在唱着“坏女巫死了”的合唱，是的。
I don't personally know the police. But I said to myself, if I had a gun, I would have shot the turkey.
我个人不认识这些警察。但我对自己说，如果我有枪，我也会射杀那只火鸡。
I think I can honestly say that we all, on this road, were glad to see him gone permanently.
我想我可以诚实地说，我们这条路上的人，都很高兴看到它永远消失。
It was just a relentless freakin' bird.
这简直是一只没完没了的该死鸟。
Those times when Tom wasn't at Jonathan's, according to neighbors, he'd been stalking them for months. And like any serial criminal, he had patterns, signatures. The first recorded sighting was on, of all days, Thanksgiving. An entire flock arrived on Roger Greeley's lawn. Suddenly, they flew up onto his porch and then marched across it, single file, led by Tom. Before he died in 2009, Roger told me it was like trying to shoo away kindergartners. They were dumb as rocks. But it all seemed so innocent at the beginning. Soon, Tom started showing up at Blue Cullen's house.
根据邻居们的说法，当汤姆不在乔纳森家的时候，它已经跟踪他们好几个月了。像任何系列罪犯一样，它有规律，有特征。第一次记录到的目击是在——偏偏是在感恩节。整群火鸡出现在罗杰·格里利（Roger Greeley）的草坪上。突然，它们飞上他的门廊，然后列队穿过，汤姆带头。在2009年去世前，罗杰告诉我说，那就像试图赶走幼儿园的孩子。它们蠢得像石头。但起初这一切似乎都很无辜。很快，汤姆开始出现在布鲁·库伦（Blue Cullen）家。
He would come chasing up to you as if he were going to peck you. He was really scary. And he just would keep coming at you. So I took to walking from my front door to my car, anytime I had to go out, with a broom. And at times I would just laugh at myself because I thought, if anybody just saw me chasing after this turkey with a broom, I would just look like a total madwoman.
它会追着你过来，好像要啄你。它真的太可怕了。它会一直向你冲来。所以我养成了一个习惯，每次出门，从前门走到车边时，手里都拿着一把扫帚。有时我会嘲笑自己，因为我想，如果有人看到我挥着扫帚追赶这只火鸡，我看起来一定像个彻头彻尾的疯女人。
My reoccurring nightmares is that I'm being chased by something, right? So all of a sudden, you have a turkey who really is bringing that to life.
我反复出现的噩梦是，我被某种东西追赶，对吧？所以突然之间，你有一只把这一切变成现实的火鸡。
Blue's niece, Stephanie DeRosa, lives one door down. Her primary battleground lay on the small stretch between her house and her car, where Tom would come after her.
布鲁的侄女，斯蒂芬妮·德罗萨（Stephanie DeRosa），住在隔壁。她的主战场位于她房子和汽车之间的小路段，汤姆经常在那儿攻击她。
I honestly ran in and got in through my passenger door, because that's what was closest to the house door, ran into the passenger door to get into the driver's seat to drive away.
我真的跑进去，从副驾驶门进去，因为那是离屋门最近的，跑进副驾驶座再爬到驾驶座开车离开。
Tom seemed to have a particular fetish for cars. Victim after victim told me stories of Tom hurling himself against vehicles, circling them maniacally, or staring down revving engines. Terrifyingly, he could keep pace with a car for the length of a city block. Stephanie remembers one time--
汤姆似乎对车有特殊的执念。受害者一个接一个地告诉我汤姆猛冲向车辆、疯狂地围着车转、或者盯着发动引擎的汽车的故事。恐怖的是，它能保持和汽车一样的速度跑完一个街区。斯蒂芬妮记得有一次——
I got into the car, and he was coming at the car. Coming at my car. I had paint chipped off of my car from this turkey. Yeah, it's terrorizing. It's a living nightmare.
我上了车，它就朝车冲过来。冲向我的车。我的车上还有被这只火鸡撞掉的漆。是的，这简直是恐怖。这是一场活生生的噩梦。
As the attacks continued, people adapted to the new regime. They learned to recognize the sound of Tom's low-slung wings scraping the gravel driveway. Some parked as close as possible to the front door to shorten the route between the car and the safety of their house. One man escorted his guesthouse tenants on walks and to their cars. After kicking and swatting, people tried defending themselves with brooms, rakes, garden hoses, golf clubs, baseball bats. A plumber had nothing on him but a hot soldering iron when Tom attacked. He wouldn't talk to us about it on tape, but he claims to have made contact and smelled cooked turkey.
随着攻击持续，人们适应了新政权。他们学会了识别汤姆那对低垂的翅膀刮擦碎石车道的响声。有些人把车停得尽可能靠近前门，以缩短从车到屋子安全地带的距离。有个男人护送他的客房租客走在路上和去车边。在踢打和拍打之后，人们尝试用扫帚、耙子、花园软管、高尔夫球棒、棒球棍来保护自己。一个管道工在汤姆攻击时身上只有一支热焊枪。他没在录音中跟我们谈这件事，但他声称接触到了它，并闻到了熟火鸡的味道。
The absurdity of it all wasn't lost on anyone. Brian Mackey, a financial director at the island's YMCA, tried to shoo away Tom with a broom and was backed 30 feet across his own yard, walking backwards, trying not to break into a run, until he knocked into a short, stone wall that he didn't see.
这种荒谬感每个人都深有体会。布莱恩·麦基（Brian Mackey），岛上基督教青年会（YMCA）的财务总监，试图用扫帚赶走汤姆，结果被逼着在自家院子里后退了30英尺，试图不跑起来，直到他撞上了一堵他没看见的矮石墙。
And I hit this wall and I went down--
我撞上这堵墙，然后倒下——
He's in his yard showing us where it happened.
他正在他的院子里给我们演示事情发生的地方。
And I'm just laying here with the broom. And it's going like-- I'm saying, what the hell is--
我正躺在这儿拿着扫帚。它发出像是——我在说，这到底是怎么——
You're lying on the ground right now.
你现在正躺在地上。
And I said, go away. You're a turkey. What are you doing here? You're not supposed to do this to me. This is my house. Get out of here. If it were a person, you could talk to it. This was a turkey.
我说，走开。你是一只火鸡。你在这里干什么？你不应该对我这么做。这是我的家。离开这儿。如果是个人，你可以和他交谈。这只是一只火鸡。
Brian told me he used to yell at Tom again and again asking, what do you want? What do you want?
布莱恩告诉我他曾一次又一次地对汤姆大喊，问它到底想要什么？你到底想要什么？
To make things worse, Tom didn't act alone. According to his victims, he had an entire rogue flock at his disposal. He seemed to have the whole group bent to his will. And they would surround people while he attacked. An electrician told me he was engulfed by a sea of nearly 40 turkeys, with Tom at the helm, who trapped him in his van.
更糟糕的是，汤姆不是单独行动。根据它的受害者们的说法，它有一整群流氓火鸡供它差遣。它似乎让整个群体都屈从于它的意志。当它攻击时，它们会包围受害者。一名电工告诉我，他被近40只火鸡包围在“海洋”里，汤姆领头，把困在了他的货车里。
The flock singled out a woman named Debbie Morelli for special treatment. Her house is close to Jonathan and Linda's, the couple that was treating Tom like a pet. The turkeys patrolled Debbie's property day and night. They'd roost in her trees, defecate in her yard and in the outdoor shower. They'd stomp around on the roof. One night, a turkey toppled into her chimney. She had to listen to it struggle and die in there. Even today, three years later, as we were asking her about Tom, she threw her head down on the table.
这群火鸡特别针对一个叫黛比·莫雷利（Debbie Morelli）的女人。她的房子离乔纳森和琳达家很近，那对把汤姆当宠物对待的夫妇。火鸡日夜在黛比的房产上巡逻。它们在她的树上栖息，在她的院子和户外淋浴间里排泄。它们在屋顶上跺脚。一天晚上，一只火鸡掉进了她的烟囱。她不得不听着它在那里面挣扎直至死去。即使是今天，三年后，当我们问她关于汤姆的事时，她把头垂在了桌子上。
I really didn't like him.
我真的不喜欢它。
Kevin Oliver is a caretaker for a bunch of summer homes on the island. One day, he got out of his car to check on one of the houses and there they were, Tom and his flock. He says it seemed like they were waiting for him.
凯文·奥利弗（Kevin Oliver）是岛上一群夏季别墅的管理员。有一天，他下车去检查其中一间屋子，结果它们在那儿，汤姆和它的那群火鸡。他说看起来它们好像就在等他。
And usually, when you come to a flock of turkeys, they run away. This group of turkeys ran towards me, so I made a bolt for the front door. And as I'm running towards the house, I finally realize that I have a handful of keys in my hand and I don't know which one belongs to the house. So I start scrambling with the keys. And as I'm doing that, the turkeys are closing in rapidly. It was just that classic horror scene where you're sitting there fumbling with the keys as creature's creeping up behind you. I finally got the right key in the door. And as I slipped in the door, the turkey's head literally came through the opening in the door.
通常情况下，当你遇到一群火鸡，它们会跑掉。但这群火鸡冲向我，所以我向着前门冲刺。当我跑向房子时，我终于意识到我手里抓着一把钥匙，但我不知道哪一个是开这房子的。所以我开始慌乱地找钥匙。当我这样做的时候，火鸡正在迅速靠近。那简直就是恐怖片里的经典场景，你坐那儿摆弄着钥匙，而生物正从你身后潜行过来。我终于把正确的钥匙插进门里。当我溜进门时，那只火鸡的头真的从门缝里伸了进来。
Tom lunged at him, snapping with his beak. If he'd slammed the door shut, Kevin could have ended things right there. But instead, he kicked Tom's head out and closed the door. The turkey then held him hostage in the house until Kevin grabbed a golf club and swung his way to the car.
汤姆向他猛扑过来，喙部啪嗒作响。如果他当时猛地关上门，凯文可能就在那儿结束这一切了。但他反而把汤姆的头踢了出去，关上了门。那只火鸡随后在屋子里把他劫为人质，直到凯文抓起一把高尔夫球棒，挥舞着杀出一条血路回到车里。
What did you think he was going to do to you if he caught you?
如果你被抓住，你觉得它会对你做什么？
Same thing I saw him do to somebody else, spur me. They have those big spurs out on the backside of their legs. And he was a big turkey. It was a big, nasty, testosterone-filled turkey.
和我看到它对别人做的一样，用距刺我。它们腿后侧长有那些大距。它是一只大火鸡。那是一只巨大、肮脏、充满睾酮的火鸡。
The attacks went on for more than six months, sometimes several times a week. Some neighbors suffered in silence, assuming they were the only ones dealing with this crazed bird. Others tried asking for help, but they had a hard time getting people to take them seriously. The chief of police said the birds weren't under his jurisdiction, same with the environmental police officer and the animal control guy, whose specialty is dogs. A few people even contacted hunters, trying to organize a contract on Tom. But no one bit. Wild turkeys are protected animals. And back in 2008, even if you had a permit, you could only hunt them for fewer than three weeks out of the year.
攻击持续了六个多月，有时一周好几次。一些邻居默默忍受，以为只有自己面对这只疯鸟。其他人尝试求助，但很难让人认真对待。警察局长说鸟类不归他管辖，环境警察和动物管理员也一样，后者的专业是狗。甚至有人联系猎人，试图组织一份针对汤姆的猎杀合约。但没人上钩。野生火鸡是受保护动物。而在2008年，即使你有许可证，你一年中也只能狩猎它们不到三周。
So lots of people found themselves in a pickle, which is why they were so relieved when those delivery people called 9-1-1 and the police finally shot him. Not only because it rid them of the bird, but also because it was proof that they hadn't imagined the whole thing. Here's Blue Cullen, the women who used to chase Tom with a broom.
所以许多人发现自己陷入了困境，这就是为什么当那些送货员拨打9-1-1，警察终于射杀它时，他们感到如此宽慰。不仅是因为它让他们摆脱了这只鸟，还因为这是他们没有臆想整件事的证明。这就是布鲁·库伦，那个曾经挥着扫帚追赶汤姆的女人。
If those people didn't have the fortitude to deal with that situation and the police literally had to shoot this bird, then I felt like, OK, maybe my anger wasn't as misplaced. If it can get to people like that too, then I'm not as cuckoo as I think I am.
如果那些人没有坚韧去处理那种情况，而警察不得不射杀这只鸟，那么我觉得，好的，也许我的愤怒并没有错。如果连那样的人都能遭此横祸，那我就没我想象的那么疯。
Why did Tom turn out this way? How did he end up attacking humans? A wildlife expert on the island speculated maybe Jonathan and Linda fed him so often that he lost his fear of people and became territorial. When he saw people in the neighborhood, especially new people, he viewed them as a threat. This expert said, that's why people should never feed wild turkeys. You're creating a monster, he said, when you start hand-feeding these animals.
汤姆为什么会变成这样？它是怎么开始攻击人类的？岛上的一位野生动物专家推测，也许是乔纳森和琳达喂它太频繁，以至于它失去了对人的恐惧，变得有了领地意识。当它在邻里看到人，尤其是新面孔时，它把他们视为威胁。这位专家说，这就是为什么人们永远不应该喂野生火鸡。你正在制造一个怪物，他说，当你开始亲手喂养这些动物时。
It's difficult to square Jonathan and Linda's description of Tom with the bird that brought an entire neighborhood to its knees. Maybe it was just a matter of perspective. Jonathan told us how Tom used to chase the UPS van. He remembered it fondly, like it was a cute game Tom and the delivery man would play together. But I spoke to that UPS guy. He wouldn't go on the record about it. But he said that turkey scared the crap out of him.
将乔纳森和琳达对汤姆的描述与让整个社区下跪的那只鸟相提并论是很困难的。也许这只是视角的问题。乔纳森告诉我们汤姆过去是如何追逐UPS货车的。他深情地回忆起这一点，就像它是汤姆和快递员一起玩的可爱游戏。但我跟那个UPS快递员谈过。他不想录音公开谈这件事。但他表示那只火鸡把他吓得半死。
But isn't that often the way with the parents of a local bully? To everyone else, he's a thug. But to mom and dad, he's a high-spirited little angel, a fluffy, injured orphan misunderstood by the world.
但这不常是当地恶霸父母的做法吗？对其他人来说，他是暴徒。但对妈妈和爸爸来说，他是充满活力的天使，一个被世界误解、毛茸茸的受伤孤儿。
I felt badly for him because he had been injured and he seemed to come over to our field a lot more than some of the other turkeys.
我为它感到难过，因为它受伤了，而且它似乎比其他一些火鸡更频繁地来到我们的田野。
And he did come back a few times with yellow paint on his face because he had been shot by someone with a paintball gun. And I guess he sort of realized that this was the place to come to when something happened.
它确实带着脸上满是黄漆又回来过几次，因为它被人用彩弹枪射击过。我想它大概意识到当发生什么事时，这里是它该来的地方。
One of the first things Linda did as her husband was being released from jail that day was call the island's emergency services number and ask for them to return Tom's body. The dispatcher was perfectly polite to Linda.
琳达在那天她丈夫获释时做的第一件事，就是拨打岛上的紧急服务号码，要求他们归还汤姆的尸体。调度员对琳达非常有礼貌。
OK, I'll see if I can get ahold of Matt and call you.
好的，我会看能不能联系到马特，然后打给你。
But then the dispatcher calls the animal control officer. And in the recording of that call, you can tell how absurd she thinks the whole thing is. It's almost like they forgot they were being recorded.
但随后调度员给动物控制员打了电话。在那个电话录音里，你可以看出她觉得整件事有多荒谬。几乎就像他们忘了自己正在被录音。
Hi, this is the Chilmark Turkey Patrol reporting in. You called me?
嗨，这里是奇尔马克火鸡巡逻队在汇报。你找我？
You're not going to believe it. You haven't started dressing it yet, have you?
你绝对不会相信。你还没开始清理它，对吧？
I did not dress it. It is in a bag in the freezer with a Chilmark P.D. label on it.
我没清理。它在冰柜里的一个袋子里，上面贴着奇尔马克警方的标签。
Because Miss [BLEEP] wants her turkey to give it a proper burial.
因为[哔——]女士想要她的火鸡，要给它举行体面的葬礼。
He tells her the police are keeping the turkey on lockdown as potential evidence.
他告诉她，警方正在将这只火鸡作为潜在证据进行封存。
I can't wait to read about this.
我等不及要读到关于这件事的报道了。
Hopefully you won't read it. I'm not part of it. This is not how I deal with turkeys.
希望你读不到。我没参与其中。这不是我处理火鸡的方式。
Never-- are they odd? Is it strange?
从来没见过——它们很奇怪吗？这很诡异吗？
I don't know. Don't know.
我不知道。不知道。
It piques my interest when somebody wants their turkey back to give it a proper burial.
当有人想找回他们的火鸡举行体面葬礼时，这激起了我的兴趣。
That's right, well. It's not going anywhere. It's safely tagged and in our freezer.
没错，好吧。它哪儿也不会去。它被安全标记并放在我们的冰柜里。
Half a year went by. After $30,000 in legal fees, all the charges against Jonathan were dropped-- assault and battery of a police officer and resisting arrest, each of which could have gotten him two and a half years in jail. And then, Jonathan says, one day the Chilmark P.D. called about Tom.
半年过去了。在支付了3万美元律师费后，针对乔纳森的所有指控都被撤销了——袭击警员和拒捕，每一项都可能让他坐两年半的牢。然后，乔纳森说，有一天奇尔马克警方打了电话关于汤姆的事。
The police had kept him for the whole six months of the appeal. And by that point, he was rather freezer burned. So this tiny little bag of this, apparently ferocious, turkey came back to us. And we buried him. And he has a headstone. I thought you'd like to know what is written on it. It's a little rock and it has a little brass plaque. And it says, "Tom the Turkey. He died as he lived." What more can you say for a wild animal?
警方在那六个月的上诉期里一直留着它。到那时，它已经严重冷冻受损了。所以这袋显然凶猛的火鸡的小袋子回到了我们手中。我们埋葬了它。它有一块墓碑。我想让你知道上面写了什么。这是一块小石头，上面有一块小铜牌。上面写着，“火鸡汤姆。它的一生正如其死时一样。”你还能对一只野生动物说什么呢？
In Jonathan, Tom had found the one guy in the woods who was in his corner, who tried to understand him on his own terms. To almost everyone else, Tom was a thug and a tough one-- gored by a hawk, pelted with paintballs, burned with a soldering iron. None of that stopped him. When Tom finally did go down, it was like Scarface in a barrage of gunfire. He lived like a bird. But he died like a gangster.
在乔纳森身上，汤姆找到了树林里唯一站在它这边、试图用它自己的方式理解它的人。对几乎其他人来说，汤姆是一个暴徒，而且是个强硬的暴徒——被鹰啄伤，被彩弹击中，被焊枪灼伤。这一切都没能阻止它。当汤姆最终倒下时，就像《疤面煞星》（Scarface）在弹雨中一样。它像一只鸟一样活着。但它像一个黑帮一样死去。
Sam Bungey. He edits the online magazine, The Racket, at theracket.net. Coming up, more birds who do not do what we want them to. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
萨姆·邦吉。他编辑在线杂志《The Racket》，网址是theracket.net。即将到来，更多不按我们意愿行事的鸟类。稍后播出。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today it is our annual "Poultry Slam," stories of chickens, turkeys, ducks, geese, foul of all kind, and our attempts to bend them to our will. We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, "Latin Liver."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同故事。今天是我们一年一度的“家禽朗诵赛”，讲述鸡、火鸡、鸭子、鹅和各种家禽的故事，以及我们试图让它们服从我们意愿的尝试。我们已经进入节目的第三幕。第三幕，“拉丁之肝”。
For a chef like Dan Barber, foie gras-- goose liver-- poses a special problem. On the one hand, he says, it's fatty. It's sweet. It makes everything near it taste incredible.
对于像丹·巴伯（Dan Barber）这样的厨师来说，鹅肝——鹅的肝脏——提出了一个特殊的问题。一方面，他说，它很肥。它很甜。它使周围的一切尝起来都令人难以置信。
Every chef loves foie gras. I've said this many times. You end up looking like a much better chef than you are if you use foie gras in all these ways.
每个厨师都喜欢鹅肝。我已经说过很多次了。如果你用各种方式使用鹅肝，你最终看起来会比实际更像一个好厨师。
But at the same time, it's also the most maligned food out there. Production has banned in many countries. Soon it's going to be illegal to serve it in the entire state of California. And it's easy to understand why. The way foie gras is made is completely inhumane. Ducks or geese are restrained. A long tube is forced down their throats. And then food is pumped into them, several meals a day, for weeks, until their livers get huge, many times their normal size. This force-feeding is called "gavage." So, like I say, problematic, right?
但与此同时，它也是最受诟病的食物。生产在许多国家已被禁止。很快，在整个加利福尼亚州供应它都将是非法的。这很容易理解为什么。鹅肝的制作方式完全是不人道的。鸭子或鹅被束缚。一根长管被强行塞进它们的喉咙。然后食物被泵入它们体内，每天几顿，持续数周，直到它们的肝脏变得巨大，比正常大好几倍。这种强迫喂食被称为“填饲”（gavage）。所以，就像我说的，有问题，对吧？
Well in 2008, Dan heard about something that he wasn't sure could possibly be true, a man named Eduardo Sousa, claiming that he was making foie gras without gavage-- no force-feeding at all. He'd just won a big French culinary prize for the stuff-- the first time a non-French person won that award. And there was a controversy about that, actually, because how could it be foie gras if he wasn't force-feeding? What he was claiming that he was doing was impossible. And there was this reporter who was doing a story about this guy, Eduardo, and the reporter asked Dan to accompany her as somebody who knew what foie gras is supposed to taste like, to verify whether or not this was, in fact, foie gras.
2008年，丹听说了一件他不确定是否可能真实的事情，一个叫爱德华多·索萨（Eduardo Sousa）的男人，声称他在不使用“填饲”的情况下制作鹅肝——完全没有强迫喂食。他刚刚因这些东西赢得了法国大奖——这是非法国人第一次获得该奖项。而且关于这一点实际上有争议，因为如果不强迫喂食，它怎么能是鹅肝呢？他声称自己正在做的事情是不可能的。有一位记者正在报道这个叫爱德华多的家伙，记者请丹陪同，作为了解鹅肝应该是什么味道的人，来验证这是否实际上是鹅肝。
I think, really, I was pretty pessimistic, I've got to say. I've had a lot of liver in my life from birds. And to get a liver that is the size of a foie gras-- the idea that you would be able to do that naturally, just-- it's impossible. It's like, how does that happen?
我想，真的，我非常悲观，我得说。我这辈子吃过很多鸟类的肝脏。想要得到一个有鹅肝那么大的肝脏——你能自然地做到这一点，这想法，只是——它是不可能的。就像，那是怎么发生的？
How big is it?
它有多大？
Well, like it's a small football. Yeah. Oh yeah.
嗯，就像一个小橄榄球。是的。噢，是的。
You mean like a Nerf football?
你是说像个泡沫橄榄球（Nerf football）？
Nerf football, sorry. Yes, right. It's a Nerf football.
泡沫橄榄球，抱歉。是的，没错。它是个泡沫橄榄球。
So Dan flew to Spain, to a region called Extremadura and went with this reporter to see this guy, Eduardo.
所以丹飞到了西班牙，一个叫埃斯特雷马杜拉（Extremadura）的地区，和那位记者一起去见这个叫爱德华多的家伙。
We arrive at the farm. And here was this man who I didn't know was Eduardo at that moment, lying in the lush grass of his farm in Extremadura with a cell phone. He was lying on his back and taking cell phone pictures of the geese all around him, oh, and cooing, of course. He was on his back cooing. In Spanish he was saying, "Lovelies, lovelies, lovelies, come around, lovelies. Over here, lovelies."
我们到达了农场。这里有一个当时我不知道是爱德华多的男人，躺在他埃斯特雷马杜拉农场郁郁葱葱的草地上，拿着手机。他躺在背上，拍摄着他周围所有鹅的手机照片，当然，还在咕咕叫。他躺在背上咕咕叫。他用西班牙语说，“宝贝们，宝贝们，宝贝们，过来，宝贝们。在这儿，宝贝们。”
It was such a bizarro-- what do you call-- horse whisperer moment. But it felt, at once, both so weird-- and I think I was jet-lagged because I had just flown in and I was just like, what am I doing with this? What is this? This is going to be a [BLEEP] waste of time, is actually what I was thinking. I remember that as my first thought. I was so sure of it.
那真是个极其奇怪的——你叫它什么——“马语者”瞬间。但它感觉既非常奇怪——我想我因为刚飞过来有严重的时差，我当时就像，我在这儿干什么？这是什么？这会是在浪费[哔——]时间，其实这就是我当时想的。我记得那是我的第一个想法。我非常肯定。
Because he just seemed like a nut.
因为他看起来就像个疯子。
Yeah. He was a nut. And I think at the moment I was like, holy Jesus, this is a waste of time, I started to question him a little more aggressively. It was one of those things where you just get agitated and tired, and you look back and you're just like, what a jerk I must have seemed.
是的。他是个疯子。我想当时我就想，天哪，这是在浪费时间，我开始更咄咄逼人地质疑他。这是那种让你变得焦躁和疲惫的事情之一，回头看，我就想，我当时看起来一定像个混蛋。
And what kind of questions were you asking?
你问了什么样的问题？
Like, so how does this work? Like, I don't get it.
比如，那这怎么运作？比如，我不明白。
So here's what Eduardo told him. He said, you don't have to force-feed geese to get them to gorge out on food, because geese gorge themselves naturally, in the wild, when they feel winter coming. It's like their preparation for winter.
所以爱德华多告诉他的是这些。他说，你不需要强迫喂鹅来让它们狼吞虎咽，因为当鹅感觉到冬天来临时，它们会在野外自然地暴饮暴食。就像它们为冬天的准备。
And so, what Eduardo does is just surround them with all kinds of incredible things to eat. It's like a goosey garden of Eden on his property. There's figs and there's olives. And there are these huge acorns. And there are all kinds of grasses. And the geese can go wherever they want, eat whatever they want. And then, when it starts to get cold, Eduardo tells Dan, they stuff themselves. That's their natural instinct. They just stuff themselves.
所以，爱德华多所做的只是用各种不可思议的食物包围它们。这就像他房产上的一个“鹅之伊甸园”。有无花果，有橄榄。还有这些巨大的橡子。还有各种各样的草。鹅想去哪儿就去哪儿，想吃什么就吃什么。然后，当天气开始变冷时，爱德华多告诉丹，它们填满自己。那是它们的本能。它们只是填满自己。
But-- and this is an important but-- for that instinct to stuff themslves to take over--
但是——这是一个重要的“但是”——为了那种“填满自己”的本能能够占据主导地位——
The geese have to believe they are free. If they do not believe they are free-- if they at all feel domesticated, and one surefire sign of domestication is fencing-- if they get food brought to them, then they don't feel wild. And if they don't feel wild, their DNA to gorge won't kick in.
鹅必须相信它们是自由的。如果它们不相信自己是自由的——如果它们有任何一点感觉到被驯化，而驯化的一个确凿标志是围栏——如果它们有食物带给它们，那么它们就不会感到野性。如果它们不感到野性，它们的基因里暴饮暴食的本能就不会被激活。
So what this means is that all the normal things that you do to raise livestock-- bringing them food, fencing them in-- Eduardo doesn't do. Dan heard this and he thought Eduardo was just lying. He thought he was actually lying. Because Dan knows, actually, a lot about farming. His restaurant has two locations and one is in Manhattan and one is on this beautiful, organic farm called Stone Barns which is 45 minutes outside of New York. And the farm is like this model organic farm. People take tours, there's an education program, and it's this super idealistic nonprofit that grows vegetables without any pesticides or chemicals. And it raises free-range animals. They have pigs and there's sheep and there's chickens. And all this is the latest environmentally-sensitive techniques for this kind of thing. And that incredible food that's produced there is served in Dan's restaurant.
这意味着你所做的所有养殖牲畜的正常事情——给它们带去食物、把它们围起来——爱德华多都不做。丹听到这个，认为爱德华多只是在撒谎。他认为他确实在撒谎。因为丹实际上对农业了解很多。他的餐厅有两个地点，一个在曼哈顿，另一个在一个叫石仓（Stone Barns）的美丽有机农场，距离纽约45分钟路程。那个农场就像这种模范有机农场。人们参加旅行，有教育项目，这是一个超级理想主义的非营利组织，种植蔬菜时不使用任何杀虫剂或化学品。它饲养散养动物。他们有猪，有羊，有鸡。所有这些都是用于此类事物的最新环保技术。而那里生产的不可思议的食物在丹的餐厅里供应。
But, even on this eco-friendly, animal-friendly farm, they feed the animals. You know? They use fences, electrified fences, to keep the predators out and to put the free-range animals on whatever field or woods is ready for them to be free-ranging, grazing, whatever. And also, to keep the animals from simply wandering off the property. They're very different from Eduardo.
但是，即使在这个生态友好、动物友好的农场，他们也喂养动物。你知道吗？他们使用围栏，电围栏，来防止掠食者并把散养动物放在任何准备好让它们散养、吃草或无论干什么的田地或树林里。而且，为了防止动物简单地溜走。他们和爱德华多非常不同。
Eduardo told Dan that the only fences that he uses are with the baby geese. And even then, he doesn't use them for very long.
爱德华多告诉丹，他使用的唯一围栏是给小鹅用的。即便如此，他也用不了多久。
So, he loses 20% to 30% of his geese to predators. That was a signal that was like-- can't be true. How do you run a business where you lose 20% or 30% of your profits in the first couple of months? So then I was just like, oh this is-- and what he said to me is, that's God's tax on raising the livers, which, you know, I'd never heard that one before. Have you? No. God's tax.
所以，他损失了20%到30%的鹅给掠食者。那是个信号，就像——不可能吧。你怎么经营一家前几个月损失20%或30%利润的企业？所以我当时就想，噢，这真是——而他对我所说的是，那是上帝对养肝的税，这，你知道，我以前从没听过那个。你听过吗？没有。上帝的税。
And the whole time that Eduardo is talking to Dan, he keeps making these motions with his hands, which Dan takes as, slow down. Wait for the translator. You're talking too fast. And he's been there for an hour or two when he realizes that, no, no, no, Eduardo wants him to lower his voice.
爱德华多和丹谈话的整个过程中，他不停地用手做出动作，丹认为那是“慢点”。等翻译。你说得太快了。他已经在那儿待了一两个小时，当他意识到，不，不，不，爱德华多是想让他放低声音。
Because I was scaring the geese. And amazingly-- I swear to God-- the geese, who I hadn't noticed because, I don't know, I'm not sensitive. I'm like a typical guy. I don't notice these things. Geese were on the other side of this area when I was talking. I lowered my voice, much like I'm doing now, nothing too extravagant. I'm lowering my voice. Within a few minutes, the geese were all up against us, all up around us. And so, maybe that's when my tune changed a little bit with him.
因为我在吓唬鹅。令人惊奇的是——我向上帝发誓——我之前没注意到鹅，因为，我不知道，我不敏感。我像个典型的男人。我不注意这些。当我说话时，鹅在那个区域的另一边。我放低了声音，就像我现在这样，没什么太夸张的。我放低了声音。几分钟之内，鹅都靠在我们身边，都围在我们周围。所以，也许那就是我对他态度改变一点的时候。
A second thing was, the geese were enormous. They were like dinosaurs and a little frightening. And what he said-- and I believed it when I finally got up close to them-- is when they get to a certain-- I think it was like eight months or something-- they fend off foxes and hyenas. They fight back and they can kill them just with their wings. And I was a little skeptical. Then I saw them-- they're big, meaty, fierce, animals. Fierce. So then I started to think, wow, he's doing something right.
第二件事是，这些鹅太巨大了。它们就像恐龙，有点吓人。他说——当我终于近距离靠近它们时，我相信了——当它们长到一定——我想是八个月左右——它们就能抵御狐狸和土狼。它们会反击，单靠翅膀就能杀死它们。我当时有点怀疑。然后我看到了它们——它们很大，肉质肥厚，凶猛。凶猛。所以我就开始想，哇，他确实做对了什么。
So then, as they're wandering around the farm, Dan witnessed something. And I didn't actually ask him about this in our interview. But he talked about this, a few months right after he visited Spain, in this speech that he gave at the TED conference. And I went to this online. And let me just play this for you.
所以，当他们在农场漫步时，丹目睹了一些事情。我在我们的采访中其实没问他这件事。但他谈到过，在他访问西班牙几个月后，他在TED大会上做过的一个演讲。我上网查了。让我为你播放这个。
So it's like, here I am on the fence about this guy. And we're sitting there and I hear [CLAPPING] from a distance. I look over and he grabs my arm and the translator's and ducks us under a bush. He says, watch this. And a squadron of geese come around. And they're getting louder, louder, louder, really loud right over us. And as they start to go past us, his geese are calling up to the wild geese. [CLAPPING]. And the wild geese are calling down. And it's getting louder and louder. And then they circle and circle, and they land. And honestly, I was like, no way. No way. I look at Eduardo who is near tears looking at this. And I say, you're telling me that your geese are calling to the wild geese to say, come for a visit.
所以就像，我在这儿对这个家伙摇摆不定。我们坐在那儿，我从远处听到[鼓掌]声。我看向那边，他抓住我的胳膊和翻译的胳膊，把我们按进灌木丛下。他说，看这个。一队鹅过来了。它们变得越来越响，越来越响，就在我们头顶上方非常响。当它们开始经过我们时，他的鹅在向上呼唤野鹅。[鼓掌]。野鹅在向下呼唤。声音越来越大。然后它们盘旋，盘旋，然后降落。老实说，我当时心想，没门。没门。我看着正在流泪看着这一切的爱德华多。我说，你是在告诉我你的鹅在呼唤野鹅说，来拜访一下吗？
And he says, no, no, no. They come to stay. They come to stay? Think about that for a minute. I mean, imagine-- I don't know-- imagine a hog farm in North Carolina. And a wild pig comes upon a factory farm and decides to stay. The DNA of a goose is to fly South in the winter, right? I said that. I said, isn't that what they're put on this earth for? To fly South in the winter and North when it gets warm? He said, no, no, no. Their DNA is to find the conditions that are conducive to life, to happiness. They find it here. They stop. They mate with his domesticated geese. And his flock continues.
他说，不，不，不。它们来是为了留下。它们来是为了留下？想想那分钟。我的意思是，想象一下——我不知道——想象一下北卡罗来纳州的一个养猪场。一只野猪来到一个工厂化农场，决定留下。鹅的基因是冬天往南飞，对吧？我说了那个。我说，这不是它们被放在地球上的原因吗？冬天往南飞，天气转暖往北飞？他说，不，不，不。它们的基因是找到有利于生命、有利于幸福的条件。它们在这里找到了。它们停下来。它们和他的家养鹅交配。他的鹅群继续壮大。
So, finally came the moment of truth, when Dan tries the foie gras. To do that, Eduardo took Dan to lunch in this tiny town in this area. And, as Dan describes it, it's like a town from an old Western. There's literally tumbleweeds rolling down the street. And there's a candy store, and a post office, and a bar. And the bar is where they go for lunch. And they are the only two customers in the bar. And the foie gras comes in this tiny little jar. And it's cold. And he spoons it out with a little spoon.
所以，终于到了那一刻，丹尝试鹅肝。为了做到这一点，爱德华多带丹去那个地区的一个小镇吃午饭。正如丹所描述的那样，这就像一部老西部片里的镇子。街道上确实有风滚草滚过。有个糖果店，一个邮局，一个酒吧。酒吧就是他们午餐去的地方。他们是酒吧里唯一的两个顾客。鹅肝放在一个小罐子里。它是冷的。他用一把小勺把它舀出来。
And then I tasted it and it's like-- what I remember thinking was, it really was the first time I ever had foie gras. That's what it felt to me. Because to say that it was the best foie gras of my life would be to cheapen it. Because it was so dramatically different. It gave me the shivers. It was really weird. It was as if I was being introduced to a new food.
然后我尝了尝，就像——我记得当时想的是，这真的是我第一次吃鹅肝。那就是我感觉到的。因为说它是这辈子最好的鹅肝会贬低它。因为它太截然不同了。它让我起鸡皮疙瘩。真的很奇怪。就好像我被介绍给了一种新的食物。
Not just a new food but an incredible new food. You know Dan's a chef, right? So he was trying to figure out, what are all these flavors that he's tasting in this liver? And it's spicy and it's fruity. And he's asking Eduardo, do you put this ingredient in? Do you put that ingredient in?
不仅是新食物，还是不可思议的新食物。你知道丹是个厨师，对吧？所以他试图弄清楚，他在这个肝脏里尝到的所有这些味道是什么？它是辛辣的，又是果味的。他问爱德华多，你加了这个配料吗？你加了那个配料吗？
I went through a list of these spices and stuff. And he was like, no. He kept shaking his head. I was like, definitely tasted some pepper spice. And then he was just like, no to pepper. I was like, no to pepper? Who doesn't put salt and pepper? So I was like, OK, so you have your foie gras and you take salt-- and he went like this. No salt. You don't use salt? He's like, no. So it turns out, all of the essences that I was tasting, all the spice, everything that I was tasting, were things that they geese were eating in Extremadura-- not those particular spices, but different grasses that had those kinds of flavors. Because he gave them access to-- according to him-- mustard grasses that I was tasting as pepper and spices. He had grasses that had a salinity to them.
我列了一堆香料之类的。而他就像，不。他一直摇头。我就想，绝对尝到了一些胡椒的味道。然后他就像，对胡椒说不。我就想，对胡椒说不？谁不用盐和胡椒？所以我就想，OK，所以你有鹅肝，然后你拿盐——而他做了这个动作。不加盐。你不加盐？他就像，不。所以结果是，我尝到的所有精华，所有的香料，我尝到的所有东西，都是鹅在埃斯特雷马杜拉吃的东西——不是那些特定的香料，而是有那种味道的不同草。因为他给了它们获取——根据他的说法——我尝作胡椒和香料的芥末草。他有带咸味的草。
For the saltiness?
为了那种咸味？
For the saltiness. And so, yeah, right? Wow.
为了那种咸味。所以，是的，对吧？哇。
What Dan was seeing was this guy, Eduardo, who was like a cook out in the field with the birds, preparing their flavor as he raised them. Though, to say raise them-- all he was doing was letting them eat whatever they wanted. And seeing this changed Dan's cooking. So much of what he serves now in his own restaurant is an attempt to present-- it's almost like the platonic ideal of the flavor of whatever meat or vegetable he's serving, and not some taste that he imposes in the kitchen.
丹所看到的是这个家伙，爱德华多，他就像个在田间和鸟儿在一起的厨师，在它们生长时准备它们的味道。虽然，说到“养它们”——他所做的只是让它们想吃什么就吃什么。看到这个改变了丹的烹饪方式。他现在在自己餐厅里供应的许多东西都是试图呈现——它几乎就像任何他供应的肉或蔬菜味道的柏拉图式理想，而不是他在厨房里强加的味道。
But beyond all that, there was also just witnessing this sheer, macho achievement of what Eduardo had done. It was hard to believe he could do this with foie gras. Foie gras was like Mount Everest. It's like the four minute mile before anybody broke the four minute mile. It's a food whose very existence depended on mistreating an animal and ignoring what nature wanted. To make it in a natural way seemed impossible. For somebody like Dan, who wanted to raise animals and vegetables in the most natural way, it was like Eduardo had flown to the moon and walked on its surface. And Dan wanted to go there too.
但除此之外，仅仅是目睹了爱德华多所做的这种纯粹的、“大男子主义”成就也令人震撼。很难相信他能用鹅肝做到这一点。鹅肝就像珠穆朗玛峰。它就像在任何人跑进四分钟英里之前的那四分钟英里一样。它是一种其存在本身就取决于虐待动物和忽视大自然意愿的食物。以自然方式制作它似乎是不可能的。对于像丹这样想以最自然方式饲养动物和蔬菜的人来说，这就像爱德华多飞到了月球并在上面行走。而丹也想去那儿。
So he decides he's going to try to make foie gras. He's going to try to make it. He's going to try to make it Eduardo's way at the farm where his food is raised. And they get some geese. And OK, here is how hard it is to try to learn something new. They raised these geese.
所以他决定他要尝试制作鹅肝。他要尝试制作它。他要在他的食物养殖的农场尝试用爱德华多的方式制作它。他们弄到了一些鹅。而OK，尝试学习新事物是多么困难。他们养了这些鹅。
We killed them and the livers were ping-pong balls. Nothing. Nothing. And I remember looking at them and just-- I was a little embarrassed. And I remember this [BLEEP] fish cook was like, well, it looks like "failed gras" to me. I'll always remember that. Steve, the fish cook-- looks like failed gras to me, dude.
我们杀了它们，肝脏就像乒乓球。什么都没有。什么都没有。我记得看着它们，只是——我有点尴尬。我记得那个[哔——]鱼厨师就像，好吧，这对我来说看起来像是“失败鹅肝”（failed gras）。我会永远记住那件事。史蒂夫，鱼厨师——伙计，这看起来像是失败鹅肝。
OK, so what went wrong? Well, for starters, Dan and the livestock manager of the farm that he's at, Craig Haney, have a much bigger predator problem than Eduardo has. They have lots of coyotes. So they didn't see a way to raise the animals without fences protecting them. Second, and probably more important, New York State is a lot colder than Spain. So during winter months when Eduardo has tons of vegetation for the geese to feed on, geese on Dan's farm-- they'd starve. Which means, in the end, Dan's geese had fences and they were fed meals.
OK，那出什么问题了？嗯，首先，丹和他所在的农场的畜牧经理克雷格·哈尼（Craig Haney）面临的掠食者问题比爱德华多的大得多。他们有大量的土狼。所以他们没看到在没有围栏保护的情况下饲养动物的方法。第二，可能更重要的是，纽约州比西班牙冷得多。所以在爱德华多有大量植被供鹅食用的冬季月份，丹农场上的鹅——它们会饿死。这意味着，最终，丹的鹅有围栏，而且它们被喂食。
And I called Eduardo again and that's when he was just like-- he said, oh no, they'll never-- this isn't going to work. It's just not going to work.
我又给爱德华多打了电话，那就是当他就像——他说，噢不，它们永远不会——这行不通。这根本行不通。
Year two they did a few things differently. For starters, rather than buy geese and have them shipped in, which totally lets the geese know they are not wild, they're like, OK, the geese need to be born here on the farm. Dan asks Eduardo to come to the United States and help him and Craig get going with this. Eduardo arrives in the US. And first stop-- the incubation room. It was cold outside and of course, you wouldn't want to throw a newly-hatched chick out into the snow, right? So they built this room to be all snug and warm for eggs to hatch and the babies to live.
第二年他们做了几件不同的事情。首先，与其买鹅并让人运来，这完全让鹅知道它们不是野生的，它们就像，OK，鹅需要在农场出生。丹请爱德华多来美国，帮助他和克雷格一起开始做这件事。爱德华多抵达美国。第一站——孵化室。外面很冷，当然，你不会想把刚孵化的小鸡扔到雪地里，对吧？所以他们建造了这个房间，让蛋孵化和婴儿生活得温暖舒适。
And so we walk in and Eduardo's eyes just go like that when he sees it. And one of Craig's assistants, one of the animal husbandry guys, sticks his hand to grab a baby chick-- in to grab it and have Eduardo look at it, at how healthy it was. And Eduardo goes, [GASP.] I was like, what the hell's going on? And Eduardo said, if you touch the chick, the oil from your hands will communicate love and domestication, protection. So they'll never get perfectly wild. He then backtracked and said, you can't have an incubation room because-- I remember what he said which is, if you're trying to create Rambo, you don't coddle him when he's born. You make him Rambo-ish by giving him the experiences to fight to be Rambo. And what we were doing was coddling and protecting. And from that moment, we were cooked. Done.
所以我们走进去，当爱德华多看到它时，他的眼睛就这样了。克雷格的一个助手，其中一个动物饲养员，伸出手去抓一只小鸡——去抓它，让爱德华多看看它有多健康。爱德华多发出，“[喘息]”。我心想，这到底是怎么回事？爱德华多说，如果你触摸小鸡，你手上的油会传达爱、驯化、保护。所以它们永远不会变得完全野性。然后他收回说，你不能有孵化室，因为——我记得他说的是，如果你试图创造兰博（Rambo），你就不会在他出生时宠溺他。你通过给他们战斗的体验来让他们变得像兰博。而我们所做的就是宠溺和保护。从那一刻起，我们就煮熟了。完了。
So year three-- get rid of the incubation. Eduardo style all the way.
所以第三年——摆脱孵化。全程爱德华多风格。
Rambo.
兰博。
Rambo. Do you know how hard it is, first of all, to get the males and the females together? Like together at the right time to get them impregnated? This is not easy stuff. Like if you've ever seen a male goose have sex with a female goose, it is barbaric, incredibly loud, and incredibly brutal. Brutal. They tear the hair out. They mount the lady goose and they tear-- they eat the hair out of the head of the female to show their superiority. And the female's bleeding and bludgeoned. And they do that all day in the spring. It is barbaric. And the visitors to Stone Barns would see this. It was crazy.
兰博。你知道首先要让公鹅和母鹅聚在一起是多么困难吗？比如在正确的时间聚在一起，让它们受孕？这可不是容易的事。比如如果你见过公鹅和母鹅性交，那是非常野蛮的，极其响亮，极其残酷。残酷。它们扯掉羽毛。它们骑在母鹅身上，它们撕——它们吃掉母鹅头上的毛来展示它们的优越感。而母鹅在流血、被打得遍体鳞伤。它们在春天整天都在那样做。那非常野蛮。而去石仓的游客会看到这个。那太疯狂了。
These nicey little people, these nice people out for their day with the children in the country.
这些漂亮的小人儿，这些和孩子在乡下过一天的漂亮人儿。
Squeaming. Squeaming lady geese. And the strutting males and the fighting males-- it was like Fight Club. So they got eggs. They layed the eggs. And the lady geese did not sit on the damn eggs. I'll give you my theory-- it's that our breed of goose that we were using-- the instinct for a mother to sit on their eggs has been bred out of them after all these years, because everyone incubates their eggs.
尖叫。尖叫的母鹅。还有雄赳赳气昂昂的公鹅和战斗的公鹅——它就像《搏击俱乐部》。所以他们弄到了蛋。它们下了蛋。而母鹅根本没坐在该死的蛋上。我会给你我的理论——这是因为我们使用的鹅品种——在经过这些年之后，母鹅坐在蛋上的本能已经在它们身上被选育掉了，因为每个人都孵化他们的蛋。
If birds don't sit on their eggs, of course, the chicks don't form inside properly. So year three-- also a bust. It just goes to show you. When you try to do things nature's way, well, nature has its own idea. Nature is not obedient little birdies having sex the way that we would want them to on a schedule that we would prefer and then gorging out on the right amount of food at the right time. After three years that could not be clearer.
如果鸟类不坐在蛋上，当然，小鸡在里面就长不好。所以第三年——也是个败局。这正好向你证明。当你尝试用大自然的方式做事时，嗯，大自然有它自己的主意。大自然不是那种以我们喜欢的进度、按照我们喜欢的 schedule 性交，然后在正确的时间暴饮暴食的顺从的小鸟儿。三年后，这一点再清楚不过了。
This coming year, they're trying again with a different breed of goose. And Dan is hoping to fence off a big swath of forest, an acre or half an acre, enough area so that the geese will hopefully feel like they are wild animals. But at the same time, they'll still be protected from coyotes. And when they put out feed for them, they're going to scatter the stuff around at random times, so the geese will just find the feed and not know that humans are there feeding them.
明年，他们正在尝试用不同品种的鹅再次尝试。丹希望围起一大片森林，一英亩或半英亩，足够的区域让鹅希望感觉它们是野生动物。但与此同时，它们仍然会免受土狼侵害。当他们为它们投放饲料时，他们会随机投放，这样鹅就会自己找到饲料，而不知道有人在那儿喂它们。
Dan, at this point, cannot help but notice how expensive all this is. Even if you could make foie gras this way-- even if it works-- it may be so labor-intensive and cost so much that it is just not worth it. He's not entirely sure that Eduardo makes profit on his foie gras. And then there's this-- Eduardo loses 30% of his birds to predators. Dan says that given the conditions in New York, he's bound to lose more. That is a lot of birds to sacrifice to get the few Rambos who are going to thrive and survive and give him foie gras. And even Dan wonders sometimes-- so many birds dying out there in the cold, is that really less cruel than gavage?
丹在这一点上，不禁注意到这一切是多么昂贵。即使你能用这种方式制作鹅肝——即使它成功了——它可能太劳动密集且成本太高，以至于根本不值得。他并不完全确定爱德华多能从他的鹅肝中获利。还有这个——爱德华多损失了30%的鸟给掠食者。丹说，考虑到纽约的情况，他注定要损失更多。为了得到那些茁壮成长、生存下来并给他鹅肝的兰博，牺牲掉的鸟实在太多了。甚至丹有时也会怀疑——那么多鸟在寒冷中死去，这真的比填饲更不残忍吗？
[MUSIC- "DON'T FENCE ME IN" BY LOUIS ARMSTRONG AND HIS ALL STARS]
[音乐 - 路易斯·阿姆斯特朗及其全明星乐团演奏的《Don't Fence Me In》]
Our program was produced today by Brian Reed with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alyssa Schip, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Production help from Mickey Meek, scouting help from the Elna Baker, music help from Damien Gray and from Rob Gettes.
今天的节目由布莱恩·里德与亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alyssa Schip）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）共同制作。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。艾米莉·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。制作帮助来自米奇·米克（Mickey Meek），勘察帮助来自埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker），音乐帮助来自达米安·格雷（Damien Gray）和罗布·盖茨（Rob Gettes）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where we have a holiday merch sale going on-- posters, DVDs, CDs, all on sale, also we just added a USB drive full of interviews that I did onstage with people like Rachel Maddow, Michael Lewis, Joss Whedon, Philip Glass many, many, more-- plus, of course, all of our old shows for free on the website www.thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站，我们那里正在进行节日商品销售——海报、DVD、CD，都在打折，我们还刚刚添加了一个USB驱动器，里面装满了我在舞台上采访雷切尔·马多（Rachel Maddow）、迈克尔·刘易斯（Michael Lewis）、乔斯·韦登（Joss Whedon）、菲利普·格拉斯（Philip Glass）等许多人的访谈——当然，还有我们在网站www.thisamericanlife.org上的所有旧节目，都是免费的。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. He's got this new way that he delivers our staff evaluations to us. He likes to print them out, roll them up--
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。WBEZ对我们节目的管理由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责。他有一种新的方式来向我们提交员工评估。他喜欢把它们打印出来，卷起来——
Into little, tiny, bead-sized balls and put those into the braids in his hair.
揉成米粒大小的小珠子，放进他头发的辫子里。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。